i'm leanna Katie I'm the news editor of
live.com and author of a new book about
steve jobs called insight Steve's brain
Steve Jobs is a genius he's the most
influential person in technology today
inside Steve's brain some pretty amazing
processes for creating modern complex
technological products the book starts
out with when he gets to Apple the
company's in huge trouble and the first
thing he has to do is lay off a lot of
people and he made sure that when they
eventually did do layoffs he didn't lay
off anybody who was really talented and
that he would need to build the next
generation of products and a good
example of that is the Newton they got
rid of the Newton a highly controversial
decision at the time that he took a lot
of flack for but he kept the Newton team
because he needed them to build the
iBook which came out a couple of years
later the way the book is always
organized is eight chapters that look at
different things at Apple as well
software design industrial design and
marketing and they're each map to assert
to a personality trait that jobs the
jobs has and its explores how that
personality trait is expressed through
Apple so for example he's a
perfectionist and what that's created at
Apple is a culture of creating prototype
after prototype whatever they do whether
it's a piece of software or an iPod or a
retail store they prototype it before
they release it so products like the
MacBook Air that was you know they made
more than a hundred prototypes for that
computer before they were happy with a
design it's it serves their purpose but
it also tends to push the technology
forward at the same time one shot has
developed a marketing I was quite
interested in the way the jobs are
struck up these really deep productive
partnerships with very very creative
people that often last for decades I
mean you know with Pete he's been
working with Jonathan Ive for 10 or 15
years the way that he recruits only what
he calls a the a-team this of
level talent to the company and gets rid
of the bozos so anybody who's media okay
anyone who doesn't measure up his
ruthlessly sort of cutout of the company
and all of that goes back to the early
days of Apple when it was a start-up
they were building computers in their
garage from the very GetGo he realized
that you can't really manage a large
team so he's always try to keep the
creative team very very small and he
learned this when he was making the
original Mac there was no more than a
hundred people if they hired a hundred
if they hired an extra person one
hundred first person somebody else had
to go somebody else had to be fired
everyone there really believes in
something bigger than just chatting out
pretty things they really want to have
an effect on culture on society and to
push the state-of-the-art in technology
so there's a real passion that comes
down from jobs but it goes down all the
way down through the company to to
making a difference
you